[Music]
all right how people settling in thank
you guys so much for for coming out
it is incredible this is our 18th talk
in this series that we call the
conversations at the interval this one
like all the others I'm very proud to
say is a sellout crowd so thank you so
much give yourselves a round of applause
for every show is better with the
sellout crowd you will know this from
going to movie premieres so but this is
this is going to be a wonderful show but
it is your excitement you guys coming
out here really makes this special and a
reminder that as always in this series
Jeffrey's going to be sticking around
afterwards myself another long now staff
from around here's we're hoping you will
stay and put the real salon part into
this salon talk series as we like to say
keep the conversation going with each
other and with our speaker tonight
please give a huge round of applause for
Jeffrey thank you Michael thank you
and I'd like to thank everybody for
coming out all friends and family and
everybody it's amazing to be able to
give a talk in the space that we helped
design it's kind of a peak moment in my
life so I'm gonna keep going before I
start crying and so the talk talking
with robots about architecture or how
automation and communication is going to
change everything we know about
buildings so as Michael said I'm
architect in California licensed
architect in California and I run a firm
called because we can we're what what's
called a design-build studio is what we
call we're over just doing Oakland not
far from here
and the difference is that we're an
architecture studio architecture firm we
do all the typical architect these sorts
of things but one of the things is that
we actually fabricate things for our own
projects to in an in-house shop that we
have over in West Oakland and sometimes
we work with other designers build
things with them for larger projects as
well so just really quick just to go
through some stuff you know we do
building's interiors furniture art both
commercial and residential we're really
into creative reuse we really love
remodels we really love working with
existing stuff that's there making the
world more interesting place you know
and we do all the stuff like the permit
drawings and the design and finding
contractors to work with the typical
architect does but then we actually make
things in-house so a great example here
in the long now is we made the bar and
we made that cabinet under the stairs
those came out of our shop in West
Oakland and were made by our team so and
we'll talk more about how that worked a
great example of a project that we do
the project types that we do is we did a
steampunk zoo in Hattiesburg Mississippi
as one does so we got a phone call they
had this they had this Galapagos
tortoise exhibit the building was half
built they wanted us to come in and
finish it out make it a kid's Science
Center so during the day they rent out
that room is used for kids science
programs then at night they rent it out
for events and stuff like that and we
themed the whole place and it's a great
example of our workflow where you know
we did a bunch of drawings we did the
typical design work but then we actually
made a lot of that stuff and then
shipped it out to Hattiesburg and handed
it off to a local contractor who did the
install and sometimes we also just make
stuff for fun you know we've made some
with friends we've worked with to make
awesome art to take out to Burning Man
we made a bunch of stuff for Maker Faire
over the years and another great example
of our work is here at the interval and
as I was saying there's a lot of
elements here in the bar that we
physically made and some stuff that was
built by contractors and some stuff that
was done by subcontractors and it's a
whole hybrid kind of workflow so I moved
here in 96 after dropping out of
architecture school and just got a job
as a CAD monkey and started working
towards my license I've always been kind
of half in the tech world and half in
the design world a early adopter of CAD
and 3d modeling and BIM and CNC tools
and digital fabrication and all that
kind of stuff always I'm always looking
for new ways of working and because of
that we've done consulting where
currently we're doing a bunch of
consulting work for the office of the
CTO at autodesk around digital
fabrication other things like that
and things in the construction industry
change both really fast and really slow
when I first moved here in 96 people
were still hand drafting at the smaller
firms right and then CAD and then the
internet and then BIM and now I PD is
like swallowing the industry and these
like kind of progressive waves but then
also you know as things are changing you
know who was in the building industry in
2008 yeah so I don't know most people
probably aren't aware of this
unemployment reached 40 percent in
certain sectors of the building industry
in 2008 with the downturn right a lot of
people got washed out of the industry so
there's in some ways it's still a very
traditional industry and when it busts
it busts hard everything is still
largely paper-based - this is our
drawing set for a house remodel that's
under the vacuum cleaner this is how I
found it at the job site you know and we
still have to submit paper to the
building department it's so there's
still these very old things mixed in
with the new things but one thing is is
that two large trends that I've seen
over the last 20 years that I think are
gonna continue rolling forward in the
next 20 years it's this idea of
automation and connection right and so I
think personally everything that can be
easily automated is eventually going to
be easily automated in the construction
industry and automation I use the term
robot kind of interchangeably for
automation so for the purpose of this
talk please you know give me that and
not you know get too technical about it
but it's kind of equivalent automation
in general and also I'm here I'm
honestly I'm really talking about for
all intents and purposes like we ki I'm
not getting into like crazy singularity
strong AI what the future could be like
a thousand years from now okay
so current this is today right today
robots do my drafting okay so I don't
draft things anymore there's a whole new
thing that came out about started using
it about ten years ago this concept
called BIM which is building information
management not going to get to a
building information modeling not get
too technical here but the basic idea
see that top left there okay that's an
image of the 3d model of one of the
buildings out at the UCF Medical Center
the new medical buildings their giant
machines just wrapped in a pretty skin
so that they're not scary to us people
when we go there like seriously they're
incredibly complex right so trying to
navigate that kind of a project with 2d
drawings on paper is almost impossible
right so this whole BIM system basically
what you do is you describe to the
computer in high detail what the
building is made out of and then that
system then produces a lot of the
drawings plans sections elevations all
that kind of stuff that you need to
submit to the building department okay
so robots are already doing our drafting
robots are also doing our field
measuring this is a laser scan of a city
square in Europe with the Wunder camera
the cabinet under the stairs here we
actually had a point cloud of the
interior space that somebody had done
and we were able to take you know the
laser measurements of that and then use
that to fabricate the cabinet that fits
right underneath there and the other
thing is this whole idea that like this
is from our friends company case Tyler
works for that company so anyway this
whole idea that you know it's more about
data than it is about drawing right and
also robots build my building so there's
this whole concept called digital
fabrication right where we have these
computer-controlled tools that cut
things out so the things I draw on a
computer or that I model on the computer
these giant robots will then carve or
cut out those pieces for me and that's
how everything you see in here was made
like we didn't cut out that cabinet that
cabinet was cut out for us by a robot
right another really interesting thing
this is our one of our CNC machines we
have one of the older ones here so this
is what I'm talking about as a giant
cutting robot in the top corner there
that's something called a total station
it's a really exciting new thing that's
coming into existence the last ten years
or so so they started making survey
equipment for jobsites robotic so that
one guy could just walk around with a
little wand and gps mark points right
and then they're like well if that
thing's robotic why don't we put a
pointing laser on it and it can point
where stuff's supposed to go right so
you feed the CAD model to it and it will
point with the laser like oh yeah the
anchors for the pipes that you're going
to hang six months from now go there and
there and
and they're you know and so it created a
feedback loop because you can measure
things on the site too with that and
then feed it back into the CAD model
back into the BIM model so if something
got put in the wrong place you know
exactly where it's at and you can
coordinate and all that kind of stuff
this is all stuff that's happening today
this is not hoo-ha future this is really
standard kind of stuff prefabrication
and pre-production I'm not talking about
the kind of hyped up dwell like we're
gonna drop a house on a site kind of pre
fabrication but like bathrooms now or
something on larger commercial projects
where they're just fabricating those
bathrooms as little units and a factory
and just bringing him out and dropping
them into the site with a crane also the
new Apple kit the new building that
they're building on the Apple Campus a
bunch of the offices and bathrooms are
all getting prefabricated in some fancy
factory somewhere brought out to the job
site dropped into place and a lot of
that is heavily automated in those
factories and then lastly this is a bit
of a joke but there are robotic
bulldozers now robotic bulldozers look
exactly like normal bulldozers which is
why I put this picture in there instead
but uh but basically they're systems now
where you feed it the CAD data of what
the site is supposed to be and a driver
just follows a line on a screen on a GPS
and the blade of the bulldozer
automatically moves to grade the site to
make it have the shape that it needs to
have right and they've been doing that
for like eight years now or something
Trimble that has that whole front to
back setup it's pretty awesome stuff so
moving forward here we're getting into
some of the more future kinds of things
is you know there's large-scale robotic
assembly which is really interesting
where you're starting to use robot arms
to actually do really interesting things
that would be hard to do by hand
there's on-site CNC tools and and you
know this kind of large-scale digital
fabrication so this is a 3d printer that
squirts out concrete to make larger size
buildings I'm pretty I'm pretty bearish
about this we can talk about that later
I don't think this is going to have much
future but it's really cool this I think
it's gonna have more future this is for
my friend Ronald Ronald real over at UC
Berkeley he's a 3d printing bricks that
go together and so this brick is shaped
of Mayan principles so that they
interlock in a way that when they shake
they fall towards their Center and the
wall doesn't fall apart and all of these
perforations make it to where the brick
cools itself when it gets wet so like
super intelligent components that he's
making for buildings automated reality
capture I think is going to just become
a much more bigger thing so this is
basically a drone flying a path every
day over a site and making a 3d model of
the site on a daily basis so you can see
like what's changing and you know what's
happening and stuff like that so robots
are now keeping track of what's going on
and another thing on the top right there
that's exciting is the whole like you
know the whole like Google glass thing
and I would make an augmented reality
sort of thing it's got a lot of hype and
then kind of crashed you know but one
area that I see huge legs for that is on
construction sites there's already apps
that you can have where you have an iPad
that basically becomes like a magic
window that you hold up to a wall and
it'll show you what it knows from the
CAD model what's in the wall
right or I'll show you what's supposed
to go there next you know and you can
like coordinate on the site with the
iPads like that the other thing is a
really creepy picture I think everything
that can be easily connected will be and
what I'm talking about connection here
I'm talking about new ways of
communicating between people and I'm
talking also about new ways of
communicating between people and robots
and new ways for the robots to talk
amongst themselves as well right and so
you know today currently connecting the
team there's a lot of stuff going on
this is cheesy cloud picture that's
required in every tech presentation
right but there is a lot of stuff that's
going on in cloud collaboration right
now it's pretty amazing to see how
radically the industry has changed in
the last five years because people had
tried to push computers out to the job
site so they could stop pushing paper
out to the job site for ever and it
never worked it always failed in some
way and then the iPad came along and now
you go out to any major construction
site and everybody has an iPad and
they're all marking up PDFs and sending
PDFs now back and forth instead of paper
right and that's like a really quick
change that has just happened recently a
lovely little detail of
that is one of the big contractors that
was the first people to do that
sorry the buses they were like you can't
give every you can't give all the people
in the field an iPad they'll just break
them right like we can't buy all these
iPads and give them to a bunch of
construction workers they'll just get
broken and so somebody came up with a
super smart idea where they're like oh
you know what this project is gonna take
five years to build four years to build
by four years the iPads are gonna be
worthless right we can't sell them to
somebody else or anything like that
let's just give all the construction
workers the iPad and tell them that it's
their iPad and if they break it they
have to buy a new one right and then
everybody was like buying cases for
their iPad and not letting anybody else
steal their iPad be like oh that's my
iPad I get to take it home like this is
mine you know and so there's social
engineering things there that are fun
there's this whole idea I P D it's
integrated project delivery and I'll
talk a little bit more about this later
in the talk but part of it is just an
attempt to remove some of the liability
involved from the traditional process of
how buildings get delivered the the
traditional architects design the
building and then hand the drawings off
to a contractor who builds the building
for the owner is just rife with problems
and lawsuits right you all hear about
all these issues that happen so one big
attempt especially for big complex
projects like the UCF medical center
that was built here in San Francisco
recently the hospital staff basically
hired a contractor and then the
contractor went and hired the engineer
and the architect and everybody else
they're all working under one contract
and their profit is held in an escrow
account and when they meet certain goals
they get their profit all right so
everybody gets paid for their time but
if you want your profit you have to work
together right it forces everybody to be
a better team and actually communicate
those sorts of things so that's been a
huge communication issue and the other
thing too is see that top right picture
so so models don't so said models don't
lie right like if I have a 3d BIM model
of my project that's that if that's
what's getting built you see that's
what's getting bailed right models can
lie it's true but for the most part like
on paper that happened because somebody
looked at a plan it looks fine and plan
right unless you unless you coordinate
that driveway with like the topo and
realize that it's not gonna work at all
you know but if you're working in like a
3d BIM
system you would see that instantly and
be like oh that's not gonna work you
know
so so again we're able to communicate
much richer because instead of me and
like the survey or me and the civil
engineer just pushing drawings back and
forth and neither of us are paying close
attention to we're actually pushing
whole 3d models back and forth that are
intelligent and have context in them
that knows it's a drive way like all
that kind of stuff
and lastly there's whole kind of big
data actual metrics like we can actually
track like who's touching what how often
they're touching it and how where the
problems are coming from and who keeps
screwing up the project as it's moving
forward and I'm serious like it's it's a
huge thing for communication and then
connecting the building itself so
actually there's a ton of interesting
things that have been going on in terms
of the building communicating with
people and with itself so who here has a
nest thermostat but a ton of people
there's one there's one here in the bar
on the wall over there and there's three
there's three of them in the bar so the
nest is a great example of how cheap
sensors are finding their ways into
buildings right consumer thing you can
buy it at Home Depot you put it on your
wall it talks to your iPhone talks to
Wi-Fi learns how to heat your house the
way you want it heated the top right
there this is cheap sensors like so that
on the top right they're actually just
embedding sensors straight into the
concrete beam that they're gonna leave
there forever and so when the next major
earthquake comes along they'll be able
to the beam will know whether it's been
compromised or not right because the
sensors are so cheap they can just put
them right into the building right so
again you know we're connecting the
buildings in a much higher level which
brings up this whole spine idea which is
something that a science fiction author
that I really like named Bruce Burt
Stirling wrote a book called shaping
things who here's read shaping things
okay it's a really it's a really cool
book he has this idea of called a spine
which is basically where you have
something and the nest is a perfect
example of this the thermostat where you
have a physical object that has some
kind of virtual identity online that is
like an adjunct to its self right so
you're not just buying a nest as a
physical product you're buying the fact
that the nest has an iPhone app that it
talks to and that that nest know
that it's that nest that's in that side
of your house and all that kind of stuff
so this idea of a spine is where the
virtual representation of that object in
the actual physical repetition of
relationship to each other and stay
related to each other over time right
and so you're starting to see a lot more
of that in the building industry a great
example I think this was a project that
was done out of Saifee which is a
special group down at Stanford that's
for researching for built environment
and facilities management and and that
kind of stuff
so he put RFID tags on everybody's
hardhat on a big job site and put little
RFID readers on the roof on the ceiling
I mean you know so anywhere you walked
in the building it knew where you were
and who was where and who was doing what
when and they could cross correlate that
data would like accident reports
productivity reports all kinds of stuff
to really understand like who was in the
building when when certain things were
happening and like really looked through
all of that data and again just be more
connected in general with what's going
on so one thing though is that so those
are the two big forces that I see that
are like rolling through and changing
the industry right you have automation
and connection communication but you
know there's things that are
counteracting those two forces that kind
of push back on it and cause those
things to come out in interesting ways
that are kind of unexpected right so
counteracting on those two trends right
it doesn't always make sense to automate
everything and it doesn't always make
sense to connect everything because
otherwise you wind up what's kind of
right the reality here is who here in
this room as actually works with robots
for a living or works with a robot okay
so you know the truth is that if a
single wire was pulled out of this
anywhere it would fall over immediately
like robots are incredibly fragile okay
like trying to automate everything is
extremely expensive because robots
aren't cheap you know a single a single
robot arm is probably three to four
people salaries for like a standard like
kind of factory worker or like labor
kind of person right you know the other
thing is that robots are really fragile
like the big Robo games that they have
out here at Fort Mason half the robots
wind up DOA from just shipping like they
break in shipping like this is this is
not terminator okay so robot
need constant maintenance robots are
mostly held together by the sheer will
of their maintained errs and a thousand
zip ties like if if Skynet ever tries to
take over we just need to make something
that corrodes zip ties and humanity is
totally safe they the other problem is
diminishing returns right like if you
try to automate something it's it's kind
of an exponential curve like if you try
to automate something a hundred percent
you know going from eighty percent to
100 percent is another like exponential
more amount of money right in that
automation process and lastly robots are
really into like they work automation
and general works really well in a
stable environment when things aren't
changing right and so if you have a
business where thing details are
changing all the time all of a sudden
your automated process isn't gonna work
anymore right the other thing with
communication is when you try to connect
everything to everything else you wind
up with a lot of friction right there's
ton like who here loves communication
standards because there's so many of
them right like it's it's great like you
know and a big part and it's a huge
problem right like okay we're gonna
standardize on this method and somebody
else standardized in another method so
now we're having to write like a special
piece of some code that translates that
method to this method and you know again
now you're adding friction you're adding
overhead connecting those things
together starts losing value there's a
lot of fragmentation there the other
thing too is when you start connecting
everything you start winding up with too
many cooks right like I mean just look
at like YouTube video comments you know
where it's like if everybody can say
something pretty soon things start
getting really like who's saying
something valuable who are we really
listening to here like things start
breaking down and you start getting too
much information like the
signal-to-noise ratio goes way off you
know and lastly who here who works for a
large company is working with a horribly
outdated like intranet system of one
kind or another or some kind of
information system inside their company
that they can't bear to deal with
anymore just because of institutional
inertia it's still there
right so another big problem with trying
to connect everything for communication
is they might have connected that system
in some awesome way like 15 years ago
and now it's a horrible albatross that
the company can't get away from because
it would cost so much money to
re-implement
something better and new that everybody
just puts up with this horrible outdated
system that's actually taking more time
and money that it's helping create you
know and also there's some things that
are just intrinsic to buildings that
make it to where automating and
connecting everything don't work like
one of the big things is like why can't
we make buildings the way Tesla makes
cars right
Tesla automated the heck out of making
these cars and you know robots do all
this assembly it's absolutely beautiful
they automated the line so that you know
it can make this car today and make a
different type of car tomorrow you know
like it's it's really impressive well
one of the big reasons why we can't make
buildings we make cars is cars are a
mass-produced item that's made entirely
from custom parts right like the doors
for a Tesla don't fit on my Subaru they
don't fit on my Prius like the doors for
a Tesla are just for a Tesla they're all
custom-made parts for a mass-produced
item right buildings are the opposite
right it's a totally custom item that's
made almost entirely from mass-produced
parts right so those are all those
pieces are just that's just timber that
you can buy from a lumberyard those
straps and stuff are off-the-shelf items
or they were just like welded up at a
shop somewhere you know buildings are
90% just off-the-shelf stuff you know
that's minimally modified if modified at
all and just put together into a totally
custom one-off thing part of that is
because of this so buildings are a
result of a lot of different forces
coming together at the same time okay so
you have cultural things that are
happening right where a building that
you know looks like a hospital here and
the Bay Area would not fly in
Philadelphia right like Philadelphia
expects a hospital look different just
culturally local culture is a big issue
there's also political issues right like
you know trying to build on the San
Francisco waterfront or trying to build
an Oakland or different areas there's
there's local codes and local government
things that you have to deal with
economics impacts areas like what's
viable to build here in California you
would cost twice as much to build
somewhere else just or take twice as
much to heat you know with the
performance issue like if you build a
typical California house and you put it
in the Arizona desert like they did in
Phoenix now you're paying hundreds of
dollars in cooling bills every summer
because you had your giant pick
your window that looked out at your
swimming pool which is a terrible idea
to have an Arizona but hey you know so
every building is this like weird
combination of hyperlocal issues right
and so it's almost impossible to think
that we could like crank out
mass-produce buildings that would fit
because everybody would want it
customized and edited for their specific
spot also the construction industry kind
of works at its own timescale right this
is from Stewart brands talk that was
here just a little while ago he was here
at that talk it was great oh cool so
this idea of paste layers these letters
move at different speeds right so we're
mostly in that infrastructure layer the
building industry is the last to adopt
new technology and that's not always
because they're stingy or like because
they're scared of new technology um not
to call you out Dylan but architect
friend of mine here how long did you
work on the Stanford project that you
worked on but how long did the project
go for it was like four or five years
right so it when it's single think of
how much technology has changed in five
years when it comes to like these things
right
there's Hospital projects that are 15 20
years in the making right by the time
the project is done whatever CAD system
you were using for the project won't run
on modern operating systems anymore
and yet you're contractually obliged by
the contract to deliver the CAD files in
that format so you're running like
virtualized systems they're running old
OS is to be able to run old CAD systems
to be able to yeah yeah it gets ugly
fast but also really big contractors
really big builders really big
developers they're really just risk and
resource managers right they're really
big contractors that are building those
hospitals or building the sky right the
skyscrapers in downtown San Francisco
they might not even have a single person
on their staff that actually does
physical construction they there are
almost finance companies at that point
where they're and there's literally like
some of the larger contractors have
people working for them that are head
almost like hedge fund managers that are
buying steel futures so seven years from
now when you buy the steel to build your
hospital it's hedged in case steel
doubles in price in that seven years
right so they're very risk-averse so
unless they know that a technology is
going to work they don't really go into
it but then also weirdly enough part of
the building industry we're
at that top layer - right where there's
last-minute changes for variety of
reasons
planning around certain things can be
really difficult like hospital projects
have to most Hospital projects because
they take five to seven years to build
by the time the project is done the MRI
machines that they plan to have in the
hospital are totally outdated now so
they purposely plan to be able to just
okay in seven years from now when they
actually buy the real machine it has to
fit in the room that we designed seven
years ago
you know so there's all this crazy stuff
that happened so the time scale to is
something that lends itself to where
it's very difficult for us to
mass-produce buildings you know in the
way that we build cars lastly - in terms
of automating stuff humans are awesome
like holy cow we're clever we're
adaptable were cheap it's awesome
like people are great like I'm serious
like trying to automate stuff past a
certain point starts getting really
diminishing turns really fast the other
thing too is there's this whole idea I'm
gonna pronounce his name wrong cuz I'm
bad with names sometimes but has seemed
to leave the fellow who wrote the Black
Swan book he wrote a book called anti
fragile is anybody read anti fragile
stay - so the concept of anti fragility
is basically that humans are anti
fragile right like when you face when a
human face is a challenge sometimes
they'll solve that challenge in a way
that creates additional value right it's
the classic inventor entrepreneur story
of like this this sucks this is a
terrible problem I came up with a
solution that solution makes is awesome
or gave me an idea for this other thing
over here that was unrelated that all of
a sudden is like awesome and that
becomes a product in its own right or a
new service or whatever they're creating
value out of thin air it's magic right
no automation can do that whatsoever
right automation is fragile it gets
faced with a challenge it breaks and it
stops working until you fix it right so
case in point just to drive that home a
little bit with the whole robots versus
humans I don't think that robots are
going to replace people wholesale at all
because I think personally that the real
money is in empowering people right like
people care about people a great example
of this is in the top left there Mozart
hundreds of years ago made a game that
if you roll dice
it will write a waltz right it's just a
random thing you roll dice it writes you
a waltz okay first year computer science
you know learning programming can write
a computer program they can just crank
out waltzes all day long
write as many waltzes as you want to
listen to in your lifetime right we
don't walk around listening to spot
waltz if I we don't like you know nobody
listens to these nobody cares about
these they're boring it's the same thing
over and over nobody made it there's no
story there there's no personality
there's no people right we care about
what other people do it's not just about
the content right it's another huge
thing to is the companies that have
empowered their people and not tried to
replace their people are the ones who
have wound up becoming massively
successful over the long term so a great
example of this is Toyota so back in the
80s Ford spent millions of dollars
buying tons of robots to try to fully
automate one of their automobile plants
around that same time in the 70s Toyota
developed the a non cord right who
here's knows about the and on cord right
so that cord is a simple piece of rope
it runs the entire assembly line anybody
on the assembly line sees a problem they
pull that rope it stops the line did
they trusted the lowest assembly worker
in the factory that if they saw a
problem that they could stop the line
and report it right you pull that cord
stops line right so this like cheap
little system is one of the many things
that made Toyota the powerhouse that
they are because everybody now is
responsible for quality and they
empowered everybody to be in control of
it right and the the giant factory that
they made if that Ford made was a total
flop was a huge failure you know this is
this giant gear ball thing that we made
for the zoo project that we did in
Mississippi it's this huge awesome it's
like eight feet wide and when you turn
the outer gear all the inner gears turn
kids love it they like play with it
constantly
nobody cares that that was made by a
robot right kids don't care that was
made by a robot it was made by a robot
but nobody cares like they just see it
they're like oh cool let's drink your
well I could play with it and spin it
and stuff like that and the other thing
too and this I love this fact it's just
absolutely fascinating I was at a
conference talking with somebody who
works with robotic arms for a living the
fancy cuca arms you know and she was
in a debate with a professor who wrote a
book on how robots are gonna replace
everybody and so he's like arguing that
case in point and she's arguing against
that very pragmatically and this fact
that she said just blows my mind she
said ok let's say we want to replace
humans with robots ok and let's say that
one robot arm replaces one person ok
that's not the case usually it's 3 to 5
robot arms replace a person on an
assembly line but let's just for the
example one arm replaces one person at
current production levels of robot arms
because robot arms aren't made by robot
arms robot arms are made by people
they're hand assembled by people there's
this complex they're completely made by
people right so if you just wanted to
make enough robot arms to replace the
people who make the robot arms in the
first place at current production levels
it would take you 15 years that's not
even meeting the demand of the rest of
the world for robot arms that's just
making enough robot arms so that the
robot arms could in theory make more
robot arms without people being involved
so again it's kind of this idea that
robots are going to be a runaway thing
it's just not in any kind of newer
timeframe whatsoever however that said
some of the solutions that I see for
some of those counteracting forces is
what I like to call semi automated and
loosely connected right so semi
automated so there's some really cool
smarter tools that are coming into
existence this thing on the top left
here is Tec Tia router these guys from
MIT they made a handheld router that's a
little robotic computer-controlled
router right so it's a little handheld
router like you'd use in woodworking but
it the router itself can move a couple
inches back and forth within the little
case that you hold right it's got a
little camera on it it's got a little
screen and what it does is you can
actually say I want to cut a straight
line from here to here and you're as
long as you keep the dot in the circle
it will adjust the router to take all
your like you know jag emotions out and
just cut a perfectly straight line right
or I want to cut a star shape out and I
don't have the skill to actually do that
by hand but the machine will totally
help you do the fine motor control to
make that work right so I think we're
gonna see a lot more stuff like that
where it's not about making some machine
like we have like we have a giant robot
that does the exact same thing and I
don't have to keep it
in a circle or anything I program it
tell what to do walk away it cut stuff
while I'm half working you know but in
this instance anybody can pick that up
and use it right you don't have to
program it you don't have no CAD you
like that kind of semi automated kind of
approach is just huge a great thing on
the top right there too is people
working alongside robots so a robot arm
like this one
that's carving out foam it will kill you
if your stand next to it right if it
swings over while you're working next to
it it will it will cause a lot of damage
to you they're big they're heavy they're
very powerful
so this thing has to be in a cage by
OSHA rules and you can't go anywhere
near it when it's working right but that
robot up there at the top that's a
special robot that this new this company
called Universal robotics is making its
all belt-driven
internally if that robot army hits you
it doesn't hurt you at all it just hits
you and and that's it like it has a slip
belt system on the inside so if it hits
something it doesn't do any damage it
just stops right so that arm is what's
loading and unloading that CNC mill that
that machinist is working at so instead
of the machinist wasting his time
loading and unloading the mill the robot
arm loads and unloads the mill and that
guy can do higher value tasks right so
semi automated like I'm not trying to
make it to where nobody's ever needed
but I'm keeping a human in the loop
because humans are awesome and they do
great jobs right but at the same time
I'm working side by side with them the
other thing is that a friend of ours
that does big massive sculptures he did
the bow and arrow on the waterfront here
in San Francisco his name's Bill
Chrysler he's a really awesome guy and
he has a CNC machine the size of a
basketball court it wouldn't fit in this
room it's a five axis machine he bought
it from a boat builder it's massive
massive thing for a lot of their
projects when they're doing complicated
sculptural work they'll actually have
the CNC router only get at about 80% of
the way there and then their talented
crew of sculptors comes in and finishes
the 20% by hand because it's faster
right
it's that 80/20 role it's like the
machine can do 80% of the work and 20%
of the time and then that lasts a little
bit of finishing work is done by hand
because that's where the artistry and
the craft really come into it to make
the piece really good they if you tried
to make it to where it came off the CNC
machine a hundred percent done you're
going to spend a hundred times the
amount of time in programming the scene
scene
machine and it still might not look as
good because it didn't have that final
touch that a talented sculptor is able
to do and lastly you know this is a
protein folding diagram one of the cool
things is when you start to make things
with robots is you can make things the
joke that we say is that you can make
things that want to be built right so if
you put all the parts in a box and you
shook the box long enough you'd wind up
with the assembled cabinet like what's
under the stairs over here right it's
it's a theoretical idea but basically we
can make it so that stuff only goes
together the right way right so again
it's semi-automated I'm not trying to
make a machine that will assemble
cabinets for me instead I'm making
really smart parts that are really
simple for anybody to put together to
make a cabinet so everything's kind of
like Ikea like or something you know and
nature is a great example of that
loosely connected so this one's a little
more esoteric but you know the movie
Rashomon right the classic Kurosawa film
where there's various truths that
everybody has from an event that really
happened you know this idea that we call
it we call it single sources of specific
truths so it's almost the opposite of
that
well we'll have is at our company we
have a couple different systems in place
where you go for specific truths right
like so if I need to know what hardware
is going into the piece that we're
building for that cabinet I go to this
in-house internet wiki ERP system that
we built right if I need to design the
parts for that system that's all in this
like BIM model system that we have but
it's a single source of truth right so
we have these like single pillars of
truth that we're reaching towards so
we're not worrying about fully
connecting those things or having every
single detail in one ruber holy grail of
a system that controls everything but
instead what we're doing is we're being
very explicit about what systems are
containing the truth
you know of that truth so that so that
we can work together in an efficient way
so it's loosely connected another thing
is the whole concept of this is a big
thing in the startup world but Co heart
metrics so the whole idea of a cohort
metric is just looking at a metric by
itself like how many accidents we had on
the job site or how many people are
looking at our website right now those
sorts of things are largely useless when
you're just looking at that one number
it's all vanity right like oh we've got
a ton of people looking at our website
like that's awesome right but knowing
how many people are looking at our
website versus how many people are
actually buying something for
who came to our website and are those
two even correlated to each other you
know like the great example is that hard
hat that I showed you earlier with the
RFID tag in it right so being able to
cross correlate accidents in the field
with which crews were where and what was
going on is really really valuable like
loosely connecting those two systems so
that we can study them in a way has a
huge amount of value and also this idea
of social making so you people in this
everybody here who's in the software
industry knows about get right like
github and all that kind of stuff
there is nothing like that in the
building industry whatsoever there's
people that are trying to make stuff
that's kind of like it it's still
probably twenty years away right just
now are we getting into where there's
some collaborative CAD systems where
it's easy for me to share files online
and collaborate with other people to
work on them there's one that we were
actually helping out with some what that
auto does has called fusion that's all
for mechanical CAD stuff where you can
truly work with other people and you can
fork and merge and all that kind of
stuff all the stuff you software people
totally take for granted for
collaboration is just now coming into
our industry and it looks like rocket
science like it's it blows people away
that you could do this right and again
it's the social making idea so we're
loosely connected to each other you know
in the fact that we're we're working
together in the in these really nice
connected systems and lastly this kind
of idea of late binding processes so
this is a great book and one of the core
points of this book is that for certain
decisions the longer you can put off the
decision the better you'll be because
you'll have more information to make the
decision so they actually discovered
that some of the architects that were
the most successful were the ones who
figured out what problems they could
ignore until the very last minute and
then would solve them at the last minute
on purpose so that they had all this new
information to then solve that problem
with right so it was able to come
together at the very end and the
software industry they call this like a
late binding kind of thing trying to
work that way in our world as well and
but then at the same time new
technologies change what's easy right so
this is another thing that's
counteracting that why you wouldn't
connect everything and automate
everything is a you know robots act as a
force multiplier I
by a CNC machine I tell the CNC machine
to do make some parts for me I leave and
I work on something else while it's
doing its job over there now I'm twice
as productive right we have two machines
now we bought a second one so we have
two giant CNC routers side-by-side I can
run them both by myself while I'm doing
a third thing right so you'd be cutting
that out cutting this thing out and then
working on my laptop like making it
quote for somebody right it's amazing
it's a really huge impact so you know
being able to automate stuff makes me
able to do higher value stuff also the
robots don't care what they're making so
that's a pant that's a closeup of the
panel's of the DeYoung museum that's in
Golden Gate Park here so all of those
panels are unique right each panel is
unique no two are the same they were
made by a CNC punch press the robot
doesn't care if they're all different
right holes are free it's what we call
it at our company like holes are free
the robot doesn't care like you know how
many holes you want what shape you want
doesn't matter so that makes it easy to
have a facade where every panel is
different right whereas before try and
have a facade where every panel is
different what it cost a gazillion
dollars and would have been impossible
would have been way too much labor to do
it right also it helps in tracking the
chaos right so some of the technology
that's been developed in CAD systems
over the last 10 years is what helped
the water bubble in the end the bird's
nest therefore the Shanghai Olympics
that got built even remotely possible to
get bailed like because the structural
engineering counts on the bird let
bird's nest alone required like huge
work from the company that did it to
make that actually stand up and work
properly so so new technologies change
things because it makes it easy
technology is getting cheaper also
changes what's easy and I like to just
show this slide because the first
laserwriter the first laser printer that
Apple came out with that kind of like
launched the desktop publishing industry
back in the 80s and it was like a huge
deal when you adjust it for inflation
it's more expensive than all the
entry-level digital fabrication tools
right now so you can go buy yourself a
3d printer or a laser cutter or like a
CNC router like we have you know for
less money than that laser writer cost
back in the 80s right so you can afford
to waste these machines right our CNC
routers we bought them for cash they can
just sit unused in the shop right they
don't have to be doing production work
day-in and day-out it used to be CNC
robots like that like robots any kind of
production robot either had to be
cranking out
Volume productions of really cheap stuff
or had to be making parts for Boeing you
know for airplanes that were
ridiculously expensive to even just pay
for itself right because it was so
expensive now they're so cheap that you
can buy one and do goofy stuff like this
with it and it's perfectly fine right
which brings me to this weird thing
where like everything old is new again
right so in the 1950s the reason that
you could do this pre-1950s
materials were expensive but people were
cheap all right labor was cheap
you could have an army of plaster
workers making these amazing facades
this is the Paramount Theatre over in
Oakland by the way it's absolutely
gorgeous on the inside so when people
are like why can't they build Victorians
that look like Victorians anymore this
is why right materials were expensive
but labor was cheap right so those
Victorian facades were all made from
local redwood and you could have an army
of people carving out doodads for you
right and then World War two happened
and for a variety of reasons labor got
expensive but materials got cheap right
which leads us to this whole modernism
sort of thing so I have these awesome
expensive materials in there but we're
not going to spend a ton of time on that
because we can't afford to right so
we're you know this kind of minimalist
design is what became really prevalent
partially for economic reasons because
you could do this and you couldn't
afford to do this anymore
right an interesting thing that's
happening is now we're kind of coming
full circle post-2000 labor because of
robots is getting cheap cheaper and
materials because of things like climate
change and the materials themselves
becoming a lot more complex is becoming
more expensive so this is a great
example this is the SFMOMA
expansion that's happening here in San
Francisco and the new skin for that all
these outside panels are being carved by
robots and then being cast in a special
fiberglass like fiber like fire
resistant G FRC
kind of panel system and you know this
is just as rich is like this right like
I mean it's it's a little more sleek and
modern because that's kind of what we're
into today but there's no reason that
that couldn't be that right robot
doesn't care it could look the same you
know and these are just some quick
renderings this is a project we're in
the middle of right now so this crazy
ceiling thing
that we're gonna make and like these
crazy seating things that we're gonna
make you know that's all gonna get cut
out by a robot you know so we can make
crazy forms and more expressive forms
and have it not cost a gazillion dollars
so things are kind of coming full circle
kind of rediscovering Wow that
architects in the room will laugh at
that rediscovering old ways of working
so this pre-litigation architecture
right so that top left there that's a
famous building by a famous architect
back at the turn of the century that
building was built where they were just
making one-to-one drawings with the
plastic with the terracotta sculptors
right so the architect would draw a
crazy elevation showing all these
doodads nothing to mentioned nothing
like specified just would draw it and
they would go and meet with the
terracotta people who would redraw it
one-to-one scale and then they would
just build it right because after the
1950's the construction industry in
general got way more lawsuit happy and
it radically changed the interaction
that the architect could have with the
actual trades people that were building
the building right now for a variety of
reasons robots and automation being one
of them and the communication being the
other that's starting to change and
we're starting to rediscover ways of
working where we're able to communicate
really highly a great example of this is
in this project like that cabinet under
the stairs we didn't make shop drawings
for that cabinet there was no drawings
that ever existed of that cabinet like a
traditional process would have been us
hiring a mill workshop showing them what
we wanted them coming out and measuring
it doing working drawings shop drawing
sending back to us signing off on it
instead we're able to just go build the
thing for the project right you know
part of this too is you have bigger
teams that talk more and the death of
this lone architect you know there's
this kind of weird cult-like obsession
with the lone visionary architect that
was almost perfectly embodied in the
horrible novel The Fountainhead sorry
just it's not horrible in the objectives
so I'm not saying that because of
philosophical reasons I'm just saying it
was a horrible character sure of what
architecture is and I've had to struggle
my whole life to argue with people that
that's not anyway representation of what
architects actually do or are so at any
rate because you have more involved and
more trust again we're back to an encore
right you have more people involved you
you're getting
more trust to those people and so again
you're kind of returning the way that we
build things like 100 years ago where
you had teams working together and a
great example if we go to Gaudi so this
is Gaudi the the famous personal and
architect top left I mean sorry top
right there so a lot of the ironwork
that is so distinctive on Gaudi
buildings was actually designed by a guy
named you Joel Wright who worked with
Gaudi and was an amazing designer zone
right Gaudi actually had a huge team of
artisans who he worked with it wasn't he
was kind of a cultural rallying point
that they all came to work with to do
this amazing stuff so it wasn't Gaudi
like this lone genius designer
it was Gaudi inspiring these other
designers who were extremely talented to
do these amazing things right and also
Gaudi was using really clever
semi-automated ways of solving problems
this is a structural model I'm sure a
lot of people here have seen this what
he did is he hung weights from chains
each weight represents a load that would
be on the building if you flip this
upside down it's basically a diagram of
the load patterns of the Sagrada família
Cathedral that he was building so he
figured out all the parabolic arches
automatically by making the building
solve itself right which without
computers because we have computers
today I can make little scripts that do
this for those seating things that I was
just showing you
I didn't model like every one of those
little panels in the seating in the
seating things here those that that
thing I didn't model those panels I drew
the overall form and then told it the
rules that I wanted it to put those
panels on there and then it made all
those panels for me and when we cut
those out a little number them all for
me and then I can just put it together
and I don't have to think about it too
hard because I'm you know want to build
cool stuff so again just to wrap things
up and these are some making of photos
over the long now I'd love to open up
for QA and thank you so much
okay alright so the first question I
have for you we talked about you've
talked about the capability is there the
tools are there the robot bulldozers are
amongst us yeah yeah but you also talked
about adoption being historically a
problem so talk to us about adoption you
guys can do all kinds of amazing right
technical things because you're small
and nimble right do you think big right
at the same time so so what's what do
you see the arc of adoption what do you
see some challenges sakes a couple
things about yeah yeah in the building
industry the arc of adoption is pretty
straightforward
usually the architects talk big about
the technology and sometimes make
pavilions or little testings
but the architects have no money really
when you boil it down to it they don't
have the money right so then what
happens is invariably these technologies
get proven in some way and then the big
contractors see that it's proven and
that it's gonna save them money and
that's when the thing actually tips so
like the adoption for the BIM stuff
we've been using it heavily for years
and really loving it and really enjoying
all the benefits that we got out of it
but the thing that made a tipping one of
the things that made a tipping point in
the industry that made it widespread
adoption was when they built the Lucas
compound in the Presidio out here
somebody did a 3d model of that in a BIM
system and they did what they call
collision detection so they ran through
the model runs through and anything
that's touching that's not supposed to
be touching it throws a alert so it's
like oh that duct is hitting that pipe
right so they were able to coordinate
all of that in 3d before they even got
to the point of making like the permit
drawings right and it saved like
millions of dollars and a guy goes to a
big goes to the builders conference
shows a presentation where he's like we
saved millions of dollars just by
spending a couple thousand dollars on
this bin thing that's and then all of a
sudden all the big contractors a couple
years laters are heavily into it so you
think that's speeding up because they've
seen a few generations of technology
improving things that they'll take a
risk earlier or do you think there's
still a pretty stiff headwind against
the stuff I think it's still honestly a
pretty stiff headwind against a lot of
the stuff because it really has to be
economically proven for the powers that
be the developers and the contractors to
really embrace it and
on that note that you UCSF Medical
Center project that I showed the BIM
model for earlier that was impossibly
complex somebody who worked on that
project you still have to submit paper
to the building department they won't
take PDFs they won't take 3d models you
submit paper write fully documented
paper so a team had to spend a huge
amount of time making a giant drawing
set that nobody's ever gonna read all
the way through everybody's gonna look
at the PDFs everybody's gonna look at
the BIM model instead that drawing set
needed a cart to move it around it was
this tall when it was on the ground when
all the drawings were put in one pile it
was like it was like waist-high pile of
drawings you know for the entire project
right and a lot of that was because of
liability because if the architect or
the engineers don't specify like every
detail then the contractor building it
runs into a problem they can then sue
and it's the fault of them and like all
this kind of stuff so there's one of the
things that by being a small design
build firm like we are is we don't have
to worry about all of those crazy
problems so we can build something like
the cabinet under the stairs without
doing any shop drawings because we don't
have to like cover our asses in case
somebody else screwed up you see what I
mean so we're able to just short-circuit
that process and jump ahead so there's
there's insurance reasons liability
reasons legal reasons and and political
reasons with building departments that
aren't changing anytime soon and so you
still have to jump through crazy hoops
because of that yes summarize that
question then so in the past the art the
artisans the the people are doing it
hands-on had a lot of that knowledge
built in to them now the tools are doing
a lot of that hands-on thing is is that
knowledge on how to do it yeah locked
into those tools no know what there's
still a craft it's kind of a different
craft bill Chrysler who does the crazy
giant sculptures loves to talk about
this topic where just because he's
making things with robots that's just a
different form of craft right there's
still a craft involved and a great
example just briefly is famous one of
the first famous lawsuits that happened
over the whole bin thing was where
Architects designed a ceiling that
couldn't physically be built right it
worked in the BIM model it worked great
in the three
no pipes touch no HVAC touched anything
like that but you would essentially have
to have all of it be instantaneously
assembled because this pipe and that
duct and everything there's no way that
you could do it and the trades don't
work that way right the trades like the
pipe guy comes in and just pipes and
leaves then plumbing and then the HVAC
guy this would have required like them
standing side by side and the guy
putting in one pipe and then the guy
putting it duct another guy putting in
fine and so the contractor sued the
design team and said this is completely
unbuildable right and the design team
overextended themselves because they're
like okay we have these crazy tools that
we can design impossibly complex stuff
and wandered into an area that they had
no domain knowledge and and wound up
creating this huge problem on the
project because they pack too much stuff
in this really narrow area you know so
so the problem is more that when people
forget about that it's not that it gets
embodied in the tools they're still a
craft there and when you don't have a
proper communication loop with the
people that are actually at the face of
work is when the big problems spin out
like that
so okay one last question from from the
bar over here yep yeah you surprised
that yes so so so the question is
basically as somebody who does both
design and fabrication some people that
do design are looking for like a
universal material that they could apply
to any problem as opposed to these
traditional materials like brick wants
to do what brick wants to do and would
kind of wants to do what wood wants to
do and steel kind of wants to do what
steel wants to do honestly for us trying
to find like a universal material that's
just abstract that we can make anything
out of anything with isn't really part
of our process at all it's never really
been something that we've even tried to
seek out because usually because of
cultural and budgetary reasons we're not
making things in the abstract we're not
making like some big noodley pavilion
form that's gonna sit in a museum
somewhere and we don't care what the
actual and material is and we're not
doing like material research science
like the ronald like ronald real is
doing like crazy 3d printing and salt
and dirt and experimenting on that end
we're making things like what's right
here right and in here the material
palette that we chose for the long now
interval was very specific because of
the machine shop blacksmith shop
traditions that this base originally had
historically as
the era that we were kind of going for
like a kind of 1940s sort of pilot in a
way but a little bit more modern and so
hence you've got like the walnut right
and this walnut in the bar is locally
harvested from somebody's backyard in in
East Bay our landlord is a honest-to-god
Japanese carpenter and has all these
trees laid up from over the years and
this is California black walnut that you
literally cannot buy you know like we
were able to get it from a source and so
we really enjoyed being able to
celebrate that materiality purposefully
in the design as opposed to trying to
make everything out of some I'm obtained
iam perfect thing that we can just mill
and it's always the same and and we can
impose our will on it instead we're
working with the materials does that
make sense okay all right thanks
everybody like I said we hope you can
stick around ask Jeff Oh Jeffrey lot
more questions
Alexander our executive director who's
right there he can explain to you the
the what ties together these
illustrations here on that auto our
drawing machine has drawn tonight if
you've got a guess as to what they are
and why they're all together let him
know we we're gonna stick around Jeffrey
I want to give you a long now challenge
going thank you thank you for being a
great speaker and everything you've done
for us let's give her a round of
applause thanks everybody thank you so
much
[Applause]
[Music]